hey man um
your new album uh is called only for
dolphins
sure is which is a remarkable name for a
project
thank you very much um i
i really think that uh latin grammys is
crazy i love the video because i know
you've always
the strong man competition guy you've
all you've been talking about
how you came up watching those
throughout the years and um yep
only for dolphins why is it named only
for the dog for for dolphins
and um it makes me want to eat mushrooms
while listening to it because i feel
like
that's what you should be doing i feel
like that's how you listen to an album
named only for dolphins
a hundred percent on white bronco i said
on the song called mount etna
yup [ __ ] don't deserve me
you know what i mean my next album's
only for dolphins
because [ __ ] don't deserve me
and that's you know
that's i've kind of run with that theme
okay this album is for the this album is
for the
guardians of the ocean that's that's
fair
um straight up i've made enough for
[ __ ] man it's time to
to give to give to the ones who really
want to receive